Pools run into real world content.
This content doesn't come from clean APIs and structured data.
You get poor quality scan PDFs, long emails, office documents
with complex tables, images, audio and video files.
This is where agents often break.
They can reason, but they cannot really read.
So by throwing raw content to your LLMS, agents scramble
with every file that comes in.
It writes custom code, uploads images to models, mysteries, tables,
skip figures and as a result quality and reliability drops
and your LLM bill goes up.
This is exactly where content understanding comes in.
Counter understanding takes a messy multimodal content and turn it
into clean structure.
Agent ready output with a single pipeline parse classified and
extract with built in grounding, confidence score and governance.
The output is well formatted Markdown a Jason files with
key value pairs that give you agent ready to act
inputs.
Now let's see it in action.
So imagine this scenario.
6:47 AM alert goes off, there's a signal degradation on
Tower Ridge corridor and 42 customers at risk today.
An on call engineer need to search 9 documents, media
files and attachments and manually investigate and correlate everything.
And this is the exact workflow we're going to try
to automate for this demo.
We will show counter understanding, turning each of the document
pulled by the alert incident into structure data including layout
tables, figures, barcodes, custom fields you define and classification and
routing.
We send that information to an agent first via just
direct call to a G PT41 for diagnose, identify and
dispatch a plan and the final act will show all
of that can be integrated seamlessly with Microsoft Agent framework.
So first step, we initialize the Contra ownership in client
very simple.
You use the same endpoint as your Azure Foundry resource
by initiating with endpoint credentials and then using the SDK
in our Python, you can make a simple prebuilt analyzer
call with document search.
Document search is one of the many prebuilt analyzers we
have in Konona Shanning.
It was a oh, how do I thank you for
all right, I think the extension did not work, but
we'll do this together.
OK, so that's the scenario.
And this is the flow that we just walked through.
And this is how you initiate the client.
So we just talked about using the Agile resource endpoint,
you can make a simple SDK call to the prebuilt
document search.
So document search is optimized for extracting document layout and
embedded elements, including tables, figures, selection marks, barcode and signatures,
and so on.
It generates rich information that you can send to downstream
applications like RAG or AI Search.
All right, so we're going to run this code to
analyze the site maintenance log.
As you can see, it has two embedded tables, a
lot of information formatted in a way that's not intuitive
for LLM agent to directly extract selection marks, QR codes
and within a few seconds you will see the counter
understanding track results.
We have two tables output preserved with a row and
column structure, one barcode QR code decoded, 2 checked and
one unchecked selection marks.
And then we further send that information to your LLM
to reason and track that as a piece of evidence.
For simple comparison, we send the same document to a
local PDF parser.
While there's not a lot of challenge with OCR, because
it's a typed PDF file, you will see that it
completely loose the table structure, raw bytes and it also
completely miss the QR code in the selection mark information.
So as a result, this is a comparison between the
two outputs.
With a local parser, your agent has incomplete information and
also have to do a lot of guessing about the
structure of the element and what each element means.
Contra understanding turns that into an LLM readable state and
then sent to agent to reason through A2 LLM input
formatting helper function, which we'll detail in the later section.
In the next act, I want to show you some
of the preview analyzer that's able to handle multimodal input.
And before we dive back into the code, I'm going
to get it start running.
I want to show you how you can use also
local Noco interface for content understanding.
Starting with our Foundry portal.
When you go to deployments and AI services, you will
be able to find content understanding playgrounds at the bottom.
So we'll go into Contour understanding playground.
We have a set of prebuilt analyzers you can use
for document, for example, for invoice.
By running this document, you'll be able to extract critical
fields values, and in the Jason output, you will be
able to see also for every text piece and value,
the offset and length, Also bounding boxes of where it
is in the documents, you can trace back to a
citation.
There's a long list of prebuilt feel free to check
out after the session and our documentation.
But here I want to show, let's say we have
an audio file that comes from crew members analyzing, inspecting
the fiber cuts situation.
So we'll send that to our audio prebuilt analyzer.
So this analyzer is able to pull out time stamps.
I am looking to transfer money to my checking account.
I have a $1000 certificate of deposit that matured last
month and I have to use it.
Sent and summarized to your LLM and agent so I
don't know if you can hear this one approaching.
Vault TV 3 visuals on the condo.
Entry.
Yeah, basically.
2 crew members exchanging information about they're approaching Vault TV
3 and then the Conduit entry.
And what?
Describe the situation with a crack and fiber bent.
The protective sleeve is completely off.
Now for other scenarios, you can also click this button
to go to our CU Studio.
In CU Studio, in the Discover tab, you can see
the list of prebuilt models you can use across tax,
legal, identity, payment, mortgage, etcetera.
Now let's go to video search.
We also have a short inspection video file that we
want to analyze before we send it to the document
analyzers.
When it comes to the neural TTS, in order to
get a good voice, it's better to have good data
to achieve life, to build a universal data, so that
this universal model is able to capture the nuance of
the audio and generate a more natural voice for the
algorithm.
What we liked about cognitive Services offerings were that they
had a much higher fidelity and they sounded a lot
more like an actual human voice.
Finished.
Let's see, it's a very short.
Clip We've got a fiber strike in this excavation, but
before the repair crew can work, we need to address
the condition around the line first.
We get a nice summary that can be sent to
the LLM for follow analysis.
All right, now let's circle back.
So basically I took the transcripts from audio and video,
send it to LLM.
Also a document file that has 6 embedded images.
After we send that to document search analyzer, as you
can see it was able to OCR all the detailed
text in the document, preserve its location as well as
in a text within doc images.
But more importantly, it generates a description with about that
image across all six photos and was able to send
to agent to reason.
Similarly, you will see that for audio and reasoning.
So LLM was able to identify the three CM 3
centimeter displacement and then also conclude by correlating up between
the two.
The root cause is around TV Vault 3.
All right.
So, so far we've talked about prebuilt analyzers, but other
scenarios agents may benefit from decision ready fields and other
times you may want to customize the field to extract
insight that's specific to your business.
So we not only allow you custom analyzers and kind
of understanding that only allows you to extract, but also
reason and infer and generate fields by calculating and reasoning.
So let's assume we have 6 different types of input
for this scenario of documents and we want to know
exactly, we want to build analyzers for each to extract
only the fields that we're interested in.
So to do so, you can simply define by identifying
your schema and then for each field the name, the
definition including the type, method and a natural language description.
Using the SDK you can deploy all of these custom
analyzers.
Another very useful type of class analyzer is called Classic
Classifier.
Similarly, you can identify categories and what they are for
any unknown document that gets sent in.
And he has the option of automatically routing any unknown
document that comes in to analyzer prebuilt or custom to
perform the purpose designed extraction.
So here we're going to do that and send the
document in.
I'm going to have it keep running.
So this is the code we said we just walked
through for the six document types, custom analyzers, we deploy
that and also creates the classifier for the six categories
and send the document one at a time to this
to this pipeline.
So this can take a minute or so to process.
We'll circle back after.
Let's review my preprocess result first.
So this is the kind of result you're going to
expect to see for each type of document.
The custom analyzer is able to return your custom defined
fields and know that some of these fields are not
found in document.
It actually requires reasoning and corroboration for the LLM to
do to generate the response.
An agent can additionally collect the evidence and reason for
the next action to take.
Also for classification, you can see all six files are
correctly identified and then routed for their respective analyzer.
So here's a quick view of the custom extraction results.
Now let's about midpoint.
Let's recap what we've seen.
Content understanding is able to take multimodal content and turn
them into text representations that can be further sent for
classification and routing to either pre build for custom analyzers
to extract fields and also infer fields and insights that's
unique to the scenario.
The next two acts want to show how an agent
can leverage all that information to perform reasoning to diagnose
the root cause, identify material, plan within budget and dispatch
what to act next.
So in this one, we're going to show a four
step agent thinking scenario, right?
So first assemble all the output from what we saw
so far from content understanding and using the two LLM
input.
It's a formatter from our SDK to the LLM.
And then it will diagnose.
We're going to send a request to diagnose the root
cause, identify the material and build plan and dispatch an
action to the recruit pair the repair crew.
So here's the results you should expect to to receive.
In the root cause analysis, we were able to identify
mechanical failure of the sheer underground conduit at Vault TV
3 caused by a microbend and a lot of details
around that.
The evidence chain is attached based on all the document
evidence we collected along the way and a final verdict
for the material plan, right.
We have information about the budget cap that it's approved
by a personnel and was able to build the materials
table to move forward with.
And finally, in the dispatch e-mail, it was able to
identify key personnel from the raw data collection process and
then send all but only the necessary information for them
to act on next.
All right, now it leads us to the final act
of content understanding integration with Microsoft Agent Framework.
So that entire process can actually be orchestrated using content
understanding context provider within Microsoft Agent Framework.
The context provider is a primitive in the agent framework
that hooks into your agent round loop.
It's able to basically see and detect messages before they
reach your LLM and act on it.
For example, it can detect attachments, process it, and then
send the structure output back to the conversation loop.
So here's how we can do it with agent framework.
First, in the setup, what you need to do is
define the context provider with content understanding, endpoint credential.
And here we're going to show the analyzer ID again
with document search.
We're also using Agent frameworks, Foundry chat client for this
scenario.
For the agent run, you can construct your agent by
identifying by providing the instructions as well as the context
provider being content understanding and you build the message by
using this simple prompt and also 9 attachments from the
PD FS.
We also going to try ask a follow up question
after we finish the first round of a diagnosis and
see how using agent framework you can use cash results
from contract and training context provider and not having to
repeat that process.
All right, we'll circle back to all the wrong results
as they're they're going for this final output, right.
You're able to see very similar result that you got
by doing the SDK pipeline manually in kind of like
one step.
And in the follow up question, the agent was able
to answer the question by using the same session and
context provider without making new content understanding calls.
So quick comparison between what we show in Act one
through 4 SDK pipeline versus Microsoft Agent Framework.
Basically it's the same underlying service for content understanding but
different integration shape.
It does provide with Microsoft Agent Framework auto analysis on
attachments, automated included formatting code and multi turn caching and
also just one provider for any type of agent.
So going back, I think our Act 3 result came
back again very similar results that we've seen Act 4
same.
We were able to see the diagnosis material dispatch.
So a couple of takeaways from the from the live
demo I want to share, right, start with prebuild document
search or other prebuilds.
When you don't know the particular document type you're analyzing
or you need to send enriched information to our lemon
agent to reason through.
For example, for RAG and AI search type of scenarios.
For other types, custom analyzer may be beneficial for you
to pull out specific fields like dispatch, urgency, budget, verdict
that are actually more reason through using counter understanding custom
analyzers and the in production.
Often times you will get payloads or a document that
you don't know the type and which analyzer to send
to you.
Use our classification and routing process for production workloads.
A single call classifieds routes and extracts and it minimizes
the branching logic in your application code.
And one thing to call out is that repeated use
of two LLM input helper function.
It's an SDK function that formats contract understanding output markdown
specifically with YAML front matter so that it's easy to
send structure information to agents to leverage.
It also has the option of choosing you send the
full document or fields only and it could result in
an arsenic or actually 85% token reduction.
There are different ways to send your current understanding output
to agents.
Agent framework simplifies the process.
We also provide direct integration with frameworks like Link chain
and mark it down so you can leverage directly.
All right, so going back to our slide very quick
to wrap up, I can find it.
OK, Yeah, I'll minimize that.
OK.
All right.
So are we presenting?
All right, so there's a lot of material.
And by the way, all this code, including the demo
app and a detailed tutorial notebook is available in the
GitHub for this demo session, and we have AQR code
for that if you want to give it a shot.
And then please check out our breakout session 242 this
afternoon at 4:00 PM to learn more about what's coming
in contradiction, including a Genentech mode that's able to handle
even more complex document scenarios and how it works with
tool boxes and Foundry.
Thank you all.